так се
на реформована куркова на корова на
олігархам а україна що травня у темні
окрус нову свій потенціал так він
чудово карти на склади сю міністри
закордонних справ fronte це не машини
за два надзвичайно насичені дні в
крові ми враховуємо ще за найму us now
не політичні сили в краї не читку
засвічу течуть про вниз про довго ж то
реформаторський курс
а не будете вигляд ходу ти ж ногу через
політичний закулісні протестуючи деякі
очевидними не можна до цього часу ти наше
основне послання до метафори на 5
сумками та прес-конференція міністра з питань
передав і так поки політики зав'язані в
боротьбі за владу більярд не поки що туди
допоможуть заходу за постріл повітря може
рушниця знайти а ще курс на реформи
нахабно на продовжите німецькі
аналітики пар ікони не я хочу українська
політична еліта чи треба з відома і
здорово там і на і густі щі проблеми з
причини для стабілізації в Україні
глибоке розчарування на заході вибираючи
адже сову за родом sim
russian і машинка знову чи треба буде
це чи щапа я знову ти тут у не меч і
не шинам потрібно їсти ти україну і
ти смути на росію ти чоловіка повернуть even
кулі слів сиди бат ще до санкції проти
росії по стану харчування ніж а йому ми
через Україну після чернь про пологів
животи санкції за поставити харчування
німецька то французька за
зовнішньополітичний курс
ви град і часто пит ринку на ходу можна
вище термін нове переформатування
муриду
стороннім донині унікальну для
сучасна україни команди реформаторі я
костюми і так одягаюся score розуму ти
повз новий ряд
у новому складі новому форматі з новими
людьми та їм відомо дадуть 100 днів теж
в лідку оновити у віри сніжок не мучити
but i з'явилися вони перші результати
путін персі результати роботи
українського дому я продуманий суворо ти
вже за лікування дні до 3 березня c день у
парижі моя ж зустрінься нормальна
четвірка україна не матчу на Франція шок
атома компроміс з Росії ще до
встановлення меру на донбасі
шлях натер у вінні вибір на попова на
територіях поважає всю темряву українську
варіант земель до закону дарства рахунок
організації цих виборів ми вже вичавлені
на парі